oui oui
[Musique]
donc nous continuons jusqu'à notre mort pour nous tenir
ici pour demander une nouvelle sœur nous sommes
ici depuis 10 ans nous avons
manifesté plus de 300 fois
devant le Parlement suédois et nous
allons nous tenir ici  jusqu'à ce qu'ils changent
le système
merci
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
d'accord d'accord
[Musique]
eh bien si le système est censé
Neutron mais la vie des hommes et des femmes
[Musique]
parce que les pensions des femmes sont bien inférieures
à celles des hommes parce que les femmes  ont
des salaires plus bas mais aussi parce que les femmes font
beaucoup plus de travail non rémunéré et
travaillent donc plus à temps partiel et parce que les femmes
ne se voient pas proposer un travail à temps plein aussi souvent
que les hommes
bonjour
[Musique]